مشاهدينا دعونا نتحدث عن قاعده او حديقه
الاتحاد الروسي طبعا هي اهم منشاه عسكريه
في العمق الروسي حيث يرتكز فيها اسطول
كبير من القاذفات الاستراتيجيه تعتمد
عليها موسكو وبدرجه كبيره في عملياتها
الدفاعيه وايضا العسكريه انجلز اذا هي
قاعده جويه عسكريه استراتيجيه تقع على بعد
14 كلم
وهي مدينه روسيه تبعد عن موسكو بحواله 858
كلم القاعده تعتبر الركيزه الاساسيه للجيش
الروسي مختلف العمليات الجويه التي يقوم
بها وخصوصا طبعا في الفتره الاخيره فمن
خلال هذه القاعده تنفذ روسيا كل عمليات
قدفات القنابل الرئيسيه وهي ايضا موقع
التشغيل الوحيد للجيش الروسي للقاذفات
الاستراتيجيه
160 تضم القاعده مدرجا بطوله 3 سميت متر
وحوالي 10 اغطيه كبيره بحيث تتمركز بها
قاذفات القنابل الاستراتيجيه للطيران بعيد
المدى قدفات تجعل من الصعب استهدافها
باعمال تقريبيه او تنفيذ ضربات سريعه
عليها ومن هذه القاعده تحديدا يمكن تنفيذ
العديد من الهجمات الصاروخيه على الاراضي
الاخرانيه بقادفات تدخل المجال الجوي لبحر
قزوين ليصل بعدها الى عمق الهدف طبعا
المدرسه جدير بالذكر ان هذه القاعده تضم
اكثر من 20 قادفت قنابل بما في ذلك تو 160
و95 ذات القدره النوويه يعد استهداف
القاعده من طرف الجيش الاوكراني مهمه صعبه
للغايه خاصه ان هذه القاعده ومنذ بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه تخضع لحراسه
عاليه المستوى